Vier Hufe und zwei Füße -
das hier sind nicht nur Reisegefährten,
sondern zwei echte Freunde.
Hallo! Ich bin die Lotta Lubkoll, und das ist
mein kleiner, frecher Esel, der Jonny.
In der Nähe von Starnberg,
südlich von München,
unternimmt die Schauspielerin
einen kleinen Ausflug mit ihrem Jonny.
Er ist ein Esel zum Pferdestehlen,
seit vier Jahren sind die beiden
ein eingespieltes Team.
Uns beide verbindet Liebe.
Das Besondere an Jonny ist, dass er mich
aus meinem stressigen Alltag rausbringt
und dass er der beste Kumpel überhaupt ist,
der beste Reisepartner
und der beste Zuhörer –
kein Wunder bei den Ohren.
Schon als Kind hat Lotta Lubkoll
den ungewöhnlichen Wunsch,
mit einem Esel auf Wanderschaft zu gehen.
Doch sie erfüllt sich ihren großen Traum
erst nach einem Schicksalsschlag.
Dann ist plötzlich mein Papa
schwer krank geworden.
2015 hat er die Diagnose
Magenkrebs bekommen,
dass es unheilbar ist und dass wir halt
nicht mehr viel Zeit miteinander haben.
Und dann habe ich mich
noch um ihn gekümmert,
bis er gestorben ist, und wir haben ganz viel,
intensiv Zeit miteinander verbracht.
Und dann hab‘ ich mich daran erinnert,
dass ich ja auch so einen Traum hab‘
schon ganz lange,
den ich gern machen möchte: mir ‘nen Esel
zu kaufen und mit dem wandern zu gehen.
Und dann dachte ich mir: Okay,
ich habe keine Ahnung, was morgen passiert:
jetzt oder nie!
Guten Morgen, Jonny!
Über eine Kleinanzeige
findet Lotta Lubkoll ihren Esel.
Es ist schnell klar:
Die beiden gehören zusammen.
Nach Monaten der Vorbereitungen
geht es im Sommer 2018 los.
Lotta Lubkoll wandert mit Jonny
von München über die Alpen
bis an die italienische Adriaküste –
rund 600 Kilometer in 80 Tagen.
Manchmal wär‘ ich auch
wesentlich schneller unterwegs gewesen,
wenn der Jonny nicht dabei gewesen wär‘,
zum Beispiel,
wenn er gerade Angst hat vor einer Brücke,
wo reißendes Wasser unten drunter ist
und die knarzt, dann hat er natürlich Angst,
dass er da einbricht.
Und dann kann das schon mal
20 Minuten dauern,
bis er sich dann über ‘ne Brücke traut.
Ja, dadurch kommt man
halt auch echt langsamer voran.
Also, wenn man Stress hat und schnell
irgendwie wohin wandern möchte,
dann würde ich keinen Esel empfehlen.
Durch ihren tierischen Gefährten
lernt sie vor allem eins:
gelassener zu werden.
Über ihre Erlebnisse,
mit einem Esel zu wandern,
hat die 28-Jährige ein Buch geschrieben.
Und das Duo bleibt eine Reisegemeinschaft.
Nun sind sie sogar motorisiert unterwegs.
Sag einmal,
du bist ja immer noch am Futtern hier.
Der umgebaute Kleinbus
ist nicht nur Wohnmobil,
sondern auch eine tiergerechte Transportbox.
So kann Esel Jonny sicher mitfahren.
Mir war es halt wichtig, dass er nicht hinten im
Hänger drinsteht,
wo ich keinen direkten Bezug zu ihm hab‘,
sondern wirklich so direkt hinter mir.
Wenn ich fahre, ist nur das Gitter dazwischen.
Ich kann mich mit ihm unterhalten
und dann sehe ich auch,
wie es ihm geht, wie steht er denn drinnen.
Ja, genau.
Und da macht er ganz gut mit.
Und zwar so gut,
dass sie sich im Dezember 2020
in ein neues tierisches Abenteuer stürzen:
mit dem Bus bis nach Portugal.
Aus Rücksicht auf Esel Jonny
fährt Lotta Lubkoll dabei nie mehr
als eine Stunde pro Tag.
Drei Monate lang sind sie unterwegs.
Jonny, wo willst du denn als Nächstes hin?
Ich glaube, als Nächstes...
also wir sind ja grad erst von ‘ner großen
Reise zurückgekommen.
Ich glaub‘, dieses Jahr gehen wir wirklich
einfach mal in den Alpen wandern
und suchen uns da
‘n paar schöne Plätze raus,
wo wir von hier halt ‘ne Stunde hinfahren
und dann einfach mal
ein paar Tage wandern können.